[dance music]
♪
- THE BLISTERITOS
PRESENTS DAD ACADEMY
CONGRADURITOS RED CARPET
VIEWING PARTY
IS OFF TO A BLISTERING START.
THERE WERE SO MANY AMAZING
GUESTS AT THE RED CARPET--
A GUY FROM PAWNSYLVANIA CAME.
- WHAT'S UP, WEIRDO?
YEAH!
- KEITH SHAWN WAS THERE.
- SO I BECAME A FASHION DESIGNER
THIS WEEK,
AND I MADE
THESE REALLY COOL BAGS.
- THESE ARE AMAZING.
- YEAH, THEY'RE REALLY GREAT.
THEY'RE NOT REVERSIBLE,
AND THEY LIGHT
ON FIRE VERY QUICKLY.
- OH, MY GOD.
THAT'S PERFECT FOR BLISTERITOS.
OH, MY GOD, IT'S KATY PERRY.
OH, MY GOD.
NICE TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
LIZ FROM PUBLIZITY.
SORRY MY HANDS ARE SO COLD.
- THAT'S OKAY.
- IT'S LIKE, OH, MY GOD,
KATY PERRY SHOWING UP?
YEAH, OKAY,
NOT A BIG DEAL.
HUGE DEAL.
- I'VE BEEN HEARING A LOT
OF THINGS ABOUT BLISTERITOS,
THAT THEY REALLY, LIKE,
ARE PAINFUL
WHEN PEOPLE PUT THEM
IN THEIR MOUTHS.
- THOSE ARE, LIKE, RUMORS, AND
THEY'VE BEEN, LIKE, DEBUNKED.
LIKE, COMPLETELY,
LIKE, DEBUNKED.
SO THERE'S NOTHING TO, LIKE,
REALLY WORRY ABOUT.
SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE YOU DO
IS JUST, LIKE,
WALK THE RED CARPET--
- YOU KNOW WHAT, I REALLY CAN'T.
I DIDN'T WANT TO
MAKE A BIG DEAL OUT OF IT,
BUT I ACTUALLY HAVE MY OWN
FLAMIN' HOT POP CHIP COMING OUT.
- CONGRADURITOS.
- I'M SORRY.
- BLISTERITOS ARE REALLY GOOD.
YOU SHOULD TRY ONE.
THEY'RE, LIKE, ACTUALLY, LIKE--
THEY'RE ACTUALLY REALLY GOOD.
- ARE YOU OKAY?
- MM-HMM.
IT'S REALLY NICE.
- SO THERE'S NO OTHER WAY OUT,
RIGHT?
- DID YOU GET ONE OF THESE?
- EXCUSE ME.
- DID YOU GET ONE
OF THESE TO HOLD?
- NO, SORRY, I CAN'T.
I CAN'T.
THIS IS A CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
- LIZ IS PREGNANT,
AND SHE'S BEING, LIKE,
A REAL BITCH RIGHT NOW,
AND I MET THIS GUY,
AND HE'S, LIKE, THE GUY
FROM BLISTERITOS,
AND, LIKE, HE'S REALLY NICE,
BUT IT'S LIKE...
[babbling incoherently]
IF YOU DON'T WALK
THE RED CARPET--
- I'M SORRY. RUTH!
both: RUTH!
RUTH!
- RUTH.
- WHO'S RUTH?
- EXCUSE ME, I HAVE TO GO.
I CAN'T ANSWER ANY MORE
OF YOUR QUESTIONS.
- OH, MY GOD, PLEASE, KATY,
PLEASE.
KATY, NO, KATY.
- NO, NO, NO, NO.
- KATY, COME HERE.
KATY.
- KATY PERRY!
I'M C-CZAR'S MOM.
HI.
- HI.
JEFFREY GURIAN
FROM COMEDY MATTERS TV.
- HEY.
- HEY, HOW ARE YOU?
- C-CZAR'S MOM.
- WOW.
- YEAH.
- YOU MUST BE SO PROUD.
- SO PROUD AND A STAR
ON DAD ACADEMY.
YOU SAW ME ON DAD ACADEMY.
- INCREDIBLE.
OH, WHAT A NIGHT FOR C-CZAR.
- SUCH A NIGHT.
MY BABY'S HERE. HAS HE TOLD YOU
ABOUT MOM ACADEMY?
- NO, HE HASN'T SAID A WORD.
- HE'S PROBABLY NOT COME DOWN
THE RED CARPET YET.
- IT'S INCREDIBLE FOR A TOILET
BABY TO COME THIS FAR.
- THERE'S REALLY NOTHING WRONG
WITH THIS STUFF.
- YOU KNOW, HE'S BRAVE,
HE'S POWERFUL.
- [groans]
WHERE'S LIZ?